foreign
hey you guys flickers of fear time once
again so if you guys remember I don't
think it was all that long ago it's
probably like in the past year I want to
say
um I read and reviewed the Scott B Smith
novel from 1993 which is called a simple
plan uh and I think that I mentioned in
there I don't know if I mentioned this
but if I didn't I should have that it's
actually probably one of the best
thrillers ever written or at least like
one of the best thrillers that I've ever
read that's for sure so um I think I
mentioned like on my review of it and I
was thinking about it while I was
reading it too
um but you know obviously there was a
really really good film adaptation of it
but I hadn't seen the movie in such a
long time that I thought that it was
about time that I did a revisit on it
like for the series especially while the
book was still like fairly fresh in my
mind like I said I don't remember
exactly when I read it but it was I
think within the past year so like the
details of it were still pretty fresh
you know so the movie came out in 1998
uh and I'm gonna have to say like this
poor movie had like a very torturous
Journey like I guess a lot of movies do
but um a really torturous Journey to the
screen and it's kind of like it was kind
of amazing for me to read about
especially considering how awesome like
the final movie turned out because I
think a lot of times like when you know
movies are this much of a [ __ ] show like
behind the scenes like you know you can
kind of see it in the final product but
you can't really in this one like this
movie turned out really good so the
director and producer Mike Nichols
actually bought the rights to the novel
before it was even published I think he
had read like a short story of Scott
Smiths and knew that he was working on
uh the novel but it hadn't been
published yet so he bought the rights to
it and Mike Nichols was actually going
to direct it himself but you know [ __ ]
went back and forth like he ended up
leaving the project to do other things
and then the screenplay which actually
Scott Smith adapted um himself like from
his own novel uh it kind of changed
hands multiple times
um everybody at one point or another
that was like Ben Stiller was gonna
direct it John Dahl was gonna direct it
John more man was gonna direct it they
were just kind of like yeah it just got
passed from hand to hand like over the
years uh and eventually
the director's chair went to the awesome
Sam Raimi who had actually been working
he'd he kind of wanted to do something
more like uh grounded or more character
driven like right around this time
period because obviously he was best
known at this point for you know like
the Evil Dead movies and he had just
done like dark man so he does kind of
these more stylized like comic book over
the top type of movies and he wanted to
do something that was like more
realistic like more like a character
drama so he was like really excited to
get on board and do this movie now the
cast went through some upheavals as well
uh I believe Nicholas Cage was supposed
to play the lead at uh one stage which
I guess that would have worked I'm not
really sure like it's hard to imagine it
with anybody else in it than who ended
up in it but you know I guess that might
have worked out and actually I think
that for a while like Anne Heche was
considered for the role of Sarah who's
like the main character's wife but
finally at long last uh the absolutely
Stellar cast that we see on the screen
now uh came together you got Bill Paxton
as Hank Mitchell who's like the main
character Billy Bob Thornton as his
brother Jacob uh Bridget Fonda as his
wife Sarah and Brent Briscoe as Lou like
the friend so Billy Bob Thornton uh and
I'm gonna say justifiably got a Best
Supporting Actor uh Oscar nomination for
this performance and I think that even
like Bill Paxton's performance he I
guess he was like apparently in the
running for like a best actor nomination
but he didn't get one unfortunately even
though I think he totally deserved it uh
Scott Smith um incidentally was also
nominated for best original screenplay
although he didn't win now in spite of
all almost Universal critical Acclaim
when this movie came out and it's just
this massive laundry list of various
Awards and nominations that it got like
seriously go to the Wikipedia page it's
just like this huge thing
um the movie Very sadly for some reason
like underperformed at the box office
like it went into like limited release I
think it was released like at the film
festivals like in September of 1998 and
then it went into limited release like
in December but I don't know for some
reason like it just didn't seem to catch
on it didn't even make its 17 million
dollar budget back like I think it only
made like 16.8 million and that finding
out that fact is just like mind-blowing
to me because a simple plan the movie
just like the book
um is really one of the most perfect
crime Thrillers ever made I mean it is
just like this gut-wrenching escalation
of suspense that even though it's two
hours it just seems like it flies by
like it never lets up for a second and
it has easily some of the the best
acting performances like in any film
from that year you know what I mean or
actually maybe even any film from the
90s so because the screenplay was
adapted by the book's author Scott Smith
it was actually cut down to its runtime
of two hours the initial draft of the
script the the movie would have been
four and a half hours long which you
know that might have been a little bit
of a slog not gonna lie
um the plot of the movie is actually
very very similar to that of the book
with only like a few changes some of
them minor some of them kind of major
one of the minor changes is that the
setting was moved from Ohio in the novel
to Minnesota in the movie because
um I guess because they needed to film
it like where there was a lot of snow
and I guess like in Ohio at that time
period there wasn't enough snow so they
had to go to like Minnesota and shoot it
there
um there were also a couple situations
that were in the book which I don't want
to spoil but just like vaguely uh in the
book there was a situation where Hank
lick lost a great deal of money like in
a condominium sale scam type thing
um there's also like the very very
gruesome murder of a convenience store
clerk and there's also kind of like a
thing at the end with like the fate of
Hank and Sarah's baby those three scenes
that were in the book were omitted from
the movie
um I'm assuming probably for time
constraint reasons and because Sam Raimi
did actually come out and say that he
wanted to soften the character of Hank
somewhat like and make him more
sympathetic than he was in the novel but
the rest of the plot like other than
that like follows the book very very
closely so the sort the story is set in
this small town in Minnesota uh where
Hank the main character he's kind of
like significantly more educated than
most of the other residents in town
because like I said it's a very very
small like Farm like rural community so
he's the only one that's like been to
college and all this other kind of stuff
and he's like a little bit
I don't want to say he's a little bit of
a snot about it like in the book he kind
of is like he's snottier in the book
than he is in the movie but he does have
a little bit of kind of like you know or
at least people perceive that he has
like a slight like superiority complex
maybe because he uses like big words and
everything like that so he's working as
an accountant in a feed store in this
town uh his wife Sarah who is pregnant
uh she works at the town's library now
Hank's brother Jacob who's played by uh
Billy Bob Thornton has some kind of like
learning disabilities uh he's unemployed
and he spends most of his kind of dead
end existence uh just getting drunk with
his kind of obnoxious and also
unemployed uh friend Lou Who Hank can
really like barely stand like they can
they're always like sniping at one
another like I like I said there's a lot
of resentment between Lou like thinking
that Hank is like too big for his
britches essentially so he's always like
talking about oh there's big words he
uses and blah blah so there's like a lot
of resentment between the two of them
now Hank and Jacob father died recently
I think in the book it was both parents
because it was an accident but I think
in the movie it's just their dad
um so Jacob actually lives on the
Family's Farm like in The Farmhouse and
he's kind of hoping one day to be able
to um kind of open the farm back up
again because I guess it's fallen on
hard times and they don't really do any
farming on the farm so he wants to kind
of follow in his Father's Footsteps and
become a farmer but he doesn't really
have the money to you know get started
so one day while Hank Jacob and Lou are
coming back I think they were visiting
the cemetery like where uh the where
their dad was buried uh fox actually
runs part of their truck and they kind
of swerve and it runs him off the road
into the snow and you know and at that
point like Jacob's dog whose name is
Mary Beth just like in the book
um runs off after the fox like so he
wants it runs up into the woods so while
the three guys are looking for the dog
who's Fine By the way
because I don't because I always worry
about that too the dog is fine okay
nothing bad happens to the talk uh so
yeah so they're looking for the dog and
they come across a crashed plane which
is partially buried in a snow bank
upon investigating this crash plane they
discover not only that the pilot of the
plane is dead and it's pretty Grody
because like all the [ __ ] crows are
like pecking out his eyes and [ __ ] like
that as they would you know Crow's got
to eat too but also uh the plane
contains a duffel bag that is stuffed
with 4.4 million dollars in hundred
dollar bills so Hank is uh pretty
immediately and probably wisely uh very
wary and so he wants to give the money
to the authorities I mean he tells the
other guys that look this money belongs
to somebody and therefore eventually
this somebody will come looking for it
Jacob and Lou though um both of whom are
like a lot more desperate for money than
Hank is like Hank's not rich but it's
like he does have a little bit more like
middle class type of existence where the
other two are just like these unemployed
like losers so um so the two of them
they argue that it's like well it's like
look it's it's in a duffel bag like who
does that this is from a crime like it's
probably like a drug dealer or something
like that and it's like probably nobody
even knows it's here No One's Gonna know
it's missing No One's Gonna Come looking
for it or call the cops for it because
it's probably from a drug trade you know
what I mean so it's like we should
totally just take it so even though Hank
is really seemed at first like to want
to do the right thing to be honest it
doesn't really take all that much
persuading like to talk him into keeping
the money
but Hank has a couple of conditions uh
if they keep it
he says um okay we can keep it but I'm
gonna hang on to it none of us can spend
any of it or tell anybody anything about
it it's like even your wives and [ __ ]
like that
um he's like I'm gonna hang on to it
until like the plane is found like after
the spring thaw so it's gonna be like a
few months and they're like once the
plane is found if nobody mentions that
any money was missing from the plane
then we will divide the loot evenly and
you know three ways and then we will
just very very quietly leave town all
separately so that nobody knows like
where we went or what we're up to so to
alleviate any suspicion like where we
got this money from
now he says if somebody does mention the
missing money like when the plane is
found
um then Hank says I'm gonna burn the
cash so we won't get busted in case
somebody comes looking for it now Jacob
and Lou are pretty reluctant to uh
concede to these conditions but um they
ultimately end up agreeing they kind of
have to because Hank's like look if you
don't I'm just gonna call the cops right
now and report this incident and none of
us will get Jack [ __ ] so it's you know
it's it's basically an ultimatum and
they're like okay fine but of course the
problems start to arise almost
immediately
um even though here's one thing even
though Hank uh very explicitly said that
he wasn't going to tell his wife Sarah
about the money and that Lou better not
tell his wife either Jacob Jacob doesn't
have a way for her girlfriend literally
the first words out of Hank's mouth like
upon coming home that evening are kind
of along the lines of hey honey
um what would you do if you found just
theoretically like if you found a random
bag of probably untraceable drug money
in the woods for example just throwing
that out there what would you do
now naturally Sarah says well you know I
would do the right thing and turn it in
it's stealing it's not my money you know
it doesn't matter where it came from but
uh you know again not surprisingly she
pretty quickly like changes her tune
when he actually like dumps this huge
pile of cash like on the table in front
of her like her eyes just [ __ ] light
up you know what I mean
um and actually she really goes all in
on the subterfuge like as soon as she
sees the the cash I mean she starts like
throwing out suggestions I mean because
it's clearly a girl's been watching some
like True Crime [ __ ] and everything like
that
um because she's like oh we should do
this that and the other like to improve
our chances of getting away with the
theft you know what I mean like she's
like criminal mastermind all of a sudden
now one of the suggestions that she
gives which actually kind of sort of
sounds reasonable on its face but ends
up spoiler alert having terrible
terrible consequences is that they
should return a small portion of the
money specifically like half a million
dollars to the plane because Sarah
reasons again you know this this is not
crazy to think this that if some
somebody is looking for the plane and
they find it then they won't suspect
that anybody took any of the money since
nobody in their right mind like that
wanted to rob it would leave half a
million dollars sitting there you know
what I mean so she's like well maybe
that'll get whoever it is like off our
backs so Hank's like okay that actually
does sound like a pretty good idea so he
actually goes back to the plane to put
some of the money back but during the
course of doing this various
circumstances unfold that tragically
ends up leading to a murder which
inevitably leads to a cover-up of said
murder and that leads to just more and
more dire consequences later on I mean
the whole thing just like snowballs and
snowballs and snowballs is they have to
keep like covering up like the worst
[ __ ] that they did like before you know
what I mean so from that point forward
like the plot really begins to thicken
big time as the three men and two women
because yes Lou told his wife about the
money too even though he said that he
wouldn't
um they try to keep the existence of the
money a secret and in the course of
doing this start developing really
really like uh deep mistrust of one
another's motives and really their uh
all of their morality just starts to uh
erode very very precipitously it's like
it's it's really something so the best
thing about a simple plan like both the
book and the movie is this just this
steadily ratcheting horror like the way
that you're kind of forced to watch
helplessly as these formerly decent
people like just regular people just
lower themselves to the worst actions
imaginable in order to keep their hands
on the loot and it keeps necessitating
them doing like worse and worse [ __ ]
it's gripping because it's so
insidiously believable like while you
know I'll give you that it might not
unfold exactly This Way in real life
while it's happening in the movie or
while you're reading it in the book you
absolutely buy into it and the hell of
it is that you can see at every step
along the way like how Hank and the
others kind of slowly paint themselves
into a corner of their own making like
you can see the reasoning behind every
single thing that they do and even
though you're just kind of like oh I
don't know if I would have done that
like you don't know because you're not
in that situation but you can totally
see why those characters acted the way
they did it's there's no there's never a
case of just like oh nobody would do
that it's like I was like oh yeah you
know people some people probably would
do that and it's just like it's kind of
like hellish like watching them because
you know that it's just gonna end like
horribly they just constantly have to do
more and more monstrous things in order
to keep the money as well as hide their
previous crimes because like I said you
know in the course of hiding the money
people end up getting murdered people
end up like all of this terrible [ __ ]
happens and so they have to keep like
covering up the cover-up you know what I
mean so it just gets like worse and
worse and snowballs like I said so I
mean even though the character of Hank
in the movie is a lot more likable and
empathetic than Hank from the novel who
actually did several very very terrible
things that were left out of the film
entirely I mean he does do terrible
things in the movie too but he did like
way worse [ __ ] in the book
um but in the movie he's still
absolutely a villain although in the
movie he's more a heartbreaking kind of
villain because he seemed like such a
nice ordinary dude like at the beginning
but the promise of all this money and
like security and how it's going to
improve the lives of him and his wife
and the baby that's on the way it ends
up like straight up turning him evil
like he ends up just doing like I said
these just monstrous things where you
wouldn't think that just a regular
person would end up doing that kind of
stuff and the same kind of thing like
applies to his wife Sarah who you know
At first she was like appalled at the
very idea of keeping this money because
it's stealing and it's not theirs but
she eventually becomes so invested in
the whole plot that she just has these
re very reasonable sounding suggestions
and the way that it just keeps
escalating it makes her just as culpable
like for the resulting [ __ ] show as Hank
is so I mean at its heart obviously a
simple plan is just a morality tale but
watching it unfold is just really really
captivating and I think a lot of that is
just because the acting in it is just
like it's so goddamn good I mean all the
acting in this is so good I think that
these might be I don't know like I'd
have to go back and say but I think
these might be my favorite performances
ever by Billy Bob Thornton and Bridget
Fonda and I think in my opinion this is
actually one of two of Bill Paxton's
best performances of his career the
other one being in Frailty which he also
directed by the way but there everybody
is [ __ ] great in this and I just
really think and it's a great story too
but I think that acting performance is
really like just put it away like a big
Notch above so yeah I mean this movie is
just like riveting and horrifying it
plays out almost like a Greek tragedy
matter of fact like because it seems
like everything is sort of faded from
the beginning and like nothing can be
done to change it like once the ball
starts rolling it's just rolling
downhill and it's like nobody's gonna be
able to do anything to like stop the
outcome you know what I mean uh because
you know the characters all become kind
of slaves to their actions with one evil
deed like necessitating the next worst
one and like you know on and on until
like I said you just get to the bottom
of the hill and everything just explodes
and the biggest gut punch of all like
comes kind of like after all of the
madness is over even though like Hank
and Sarah at least kind of are allowed
to return to some semblance of their
previous lives they now have to do that
with the knowledge of all the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] that they did and deal with the
fact that they're formerly happy
satisfactory lives are now like tainted
like they're not good anymore because of
all the [ __ ] they had to do because
everything was just been tainted by
greed and the knowledge of the [ __ ] that
they did like in the service of that
greed so now like their lives are
significant like they're significantly
worse off than they were before they
found the money you know what I mean so
now while I will say that the book is a
lot more brutal than the movie just in
terms of like how bad [ __ ] gets and like
how like some of the you know evil uh
Deeds that some of the characters do
that were a few of which were left out
of the movie I do understand why Sam
raymie chose to kind of tone down the
events for the movie just a little bit
and I think it was actually the right
decision I mean not only would some of
the more [ __ ] up incidents from the
book have I think made the movie a
little bit less believable I mean they
work totally fine in the book but you
know like I said it's you know it's it's
different like doing things in a book
and in a movie Sometimes you can get
away with a lot more stuff than you in a
book than you can in a movie and I think
this is a case where that happened and
it's good that Sam Raimi recognized that
maybe I think too that like I said he
wanted to make Hank a little bit more
relatable and maybe like slightly less
evil like you felt kind of more bad for
him whereas in the book he was kind of
he was more of a dick you know what I
mean and and I think like the the
horrifying of the book came from just
like even though he was just a regular
dude at the beginning but just like how
[ __ ] bad it got and how he got to
this place you know what I mean whereas
in the movie I think it's a lot more
emotionally affecting and a lot more
tragic because he seemed like such a
nice man and he ended up doing just
horrible horrible [ __ ] and you kind of
put yourself in the shoes of that it's
like oh my God like would I do the same
thing like this escalating [ __ ] [ __ ]
show would the same thing happened like
if I found all that money you know what
I mean it's totally possible that it
could so both the book and the movie are
absolutely worth your time if you like
Thrillers because like I said it's
probably like the best ones I ever saw
slash red
um although they are very similar plot
wise I wouldn't hesitate to recommend
both of them and I think probably if you
like the movie you should read the book
and vice versa because the tone in both
the book and the movie is slightly
different like they kind of come at it
from a little bit of a different angle
like I think each of them brings like a
a little bit of a distinct spin like on
what is essentially the same story but
they're both absolutely really good so
if you've read the book or seen the
movie or both or whatever let me know
what you think about them in the
comments and that'll do it for this
flickers of fear I'll see you guys again
on the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]